[__] you been I was on vacation I don't
take [__] vacations but I had to take
a vacation I got a wife and a child now
and I got to act like a [__]
individual I can't just I didn't take my
listen I was with my wife 15 years and
never took her to New York really that's
where I'm from never [__] never never
I'm not in the mood I only go back there
to do comedy I don't go back there to
dilly d when I go back when I go back to
New York I fly in I go to my favorite
Chinese restaurant I do radio the next
day after [__] radio I go to the
cemetery I put flowers on my mom grave
and then I do my four [__] shows and
I get the [__] out of him the first
flight on Sunday just like I do every
other goddamn City that's it I try to
see some people in between you know a
school teacher or two maybe you know
something really yeah I still talk to my
school teachers two of them I was going
to go to dinner with the one but he had
to take his uh grandkid out of the
hospital he wanted to meet me later on
but we would leaving early so I couldn't
meet him at 10 that's fcking awesome dud
so you know we never really took a break
podcast and we did last Monday and last
Wednesday I took off Monday we were
going to do last night but I tell you
Theo I hate [__] doing podcast when
I'm tired I hate I don't want to give
nobody as Jimmy schuber says the short
shrip you follow me I was just out of it
last night the 5 and a half hour flight
with the [__] bab oh that's miserable
dude see by myself I eat a [__] pot
cookie and I get stoned I fall sleep for
half when you have the family you got to
be and I got caught smoking Vapor on the
[__] pen
tremendous I had one of those uh vapor
pens I just filled it up it was it was
just brand new I took the inhaler with
me they have an asthma inhaler now so I
took for the pot for the reefer oh it's
dabs it [__] you up so I took that with
me to New York and I sprayed it twice
you know a couple times on the plane and
it kept me there then I hit it when I
was in New York and I hit it with Ari
when I went over to see the tree and the
[__] sax Fifth Avenue and all that
[__] and I ran out so I had this brand
new tube it's a gram of oil from par R
and I opened it up before I got in the
plane I charged it up first 10 hits it's
like [__] death hits like they just
[__] clouds of smoke so I hit it two
times then I got in the plane like two
hours into the flight look at my
daughter and every time I would hit it
it would go by my daughter cuz she had
the window seat so I go I can't let her
have it so I go let me go to the
bathroom I'm in the bathroom with the
[__] iPod on listening to Pink floor
no you're not yes I am I got the I this
is how [__] crazy I am I'm not listen
it's wish you were here that's the album
I'm listening to CU it was like Shine On
You Crazy Diamond and have a cigar I'm I
ate Edibles I had uh I had like three
four red stars left so you had a little
magic in your system oh I was [__] I
had I was [__] up for the first two
and a half hours cuz I got I didn't get
[__] up on the way there and it made a
big difference I got agitated at the 2
hour mark at the two and a half hour
mark if you don't have something once
the move once Madden Max is finished
you're ready to kill a [__] on a
flight Madden Max is not the move movie
to watch on a [__] plane cuz there
you are sitting everybody's driving
jumping over people and [__] shooting
[__] and you're sitting there
next to like some [__] politician or
some [__] you want to get up you want to
get up so I said [__] that so I dosed
myself on the way out I had virgin I had
main cabin select it's the one behind
first class so we could all sit together
because in first class we couldn't all
sit together I would have to sit by
myself and she'd be [__] crawling
back and forth like [__] that just get
the main cabin select how tall is the
child you have she's the [__] [__]
she's three you know she's just a little
baby but how tall do you think she is ah
she's up to oh that's that's not very
tall no she's a little baby oh that's
not so I got up I go to the bathroom I
close the [__] door and I'm in there
and I'm hitting this pen and I see
clouds the oan I'm like wow what color
was that [__] clouds of smoke and I'm
hitting this vapor and I'm hitting this
[__] s with your iPod on with the
iPod on listen to [__] Shine On You
Crazy Diamond he and all of a sudden I
hear and I see the little red light
going on and they're like open up are
you smoking in there and I put the thing
in my pocket and I take this out and I
blow a couple clouds of this [__] and I
go hold on like I'm put my dick in my
pants which I really did piss and then I
[__] wash my hands and I what's the
problem and she goes were you smoking in
here I go no wow I go do I look like I
was smoking in here I look like and she
looked at me she goes this is smell like
smoke and she took oh they take
everything out the garbage they do
everything they look for this cigarette
yeah oh wow and now what were you doing
the whole time to standing there like
I'm standing there going I don't know
what happened I banged it when I came in
the plane shifted and I hit the wall and
that's the next thing you know you
people were knocking on my thing and
they're like we don't smell no smoke I
wonder what made it go off and I'm
sitting there going they [__] know
they're just playing me oh really but
then they were cool the rest of the
fight Espionage bro I sat there they
were cool and at the end I gave my wife
the keys I told my wife I go listen they
called me in the
bathroom uh I'm going to get arrested so
take the car keys I'll see you at the
house what did she say she just [__]
looked the other way and like shook a
head what is my wife going to [__]
say at this age damn I'm 50 what are
they going to say to me you punch well
and then I walked off the [__] plane
like I owned La nobody said dick to me
that did you think though somewhere in
your head that whenever you got to La
there was going to be people oh [__]
yeah they've been waiting for me before
I've been approached at the plane one
time on the way to Columbus I is it kind
of cool or is it just [__] not
cool if you're getting off a plane you
got an ounce of weed in your nut sack
yeah it ain't [__] cool be
uncomfortable the plane and you're cool
you know you don't like the one time I
was in Columbus I had weed on me and
some guy said I didn't do nothing he
leaned back and I hold on one second he
turned around goes [__] you so I said
[__] you or something I kicked the chair
and he went and told the store so I was
the bad guy the rest of the [__]
flight oh jeez and then do you start to
feel like the [__] bad guy too you're
like oh you want a bad guy start saying
[__] in your head you want a [__] bad
guy [__] with me [__] suck put that seat
back again and here's what happened we
went to Columbus they got us off the
plane they got uh statements from both
of us and they let us go and a year L I
got on the plane that same [__] guy's
on the plane go how you doing and he
just sat there the whole time like a
little
[__] so in all your years of being on
the plane and like having weed under
your nut and all that you never once
smoked a cigarette in the plane no wow
in 1983 I was flying you used to be able
to didn't you yeah you could smoke in
the FL in the flights in Russia you
can't have heard really mhm do anything
in Russia uhuh but I heard that you can
though you could smoke in that in like
certain areas you could smoke on a plane
but I'll tell you what I did see one
[__] time
though uh [__] you broke my taint I
don't even know what I was in the s in
there smoking on a plane smoking on a
plane smoking on a Russ you never once
smoked on a plane yeah no but in 1984
February 1984 I got on the plane in in
Aspen it was Aspen Denver Denver Jersey
on the way back from Denver the Jersey
there was a soldier next to me and I had
a brown Bowl in weed and I'm like you
want to get high that's when you can
smoke cigarettes on a plane he's like
let's go do it we went to the back
[__] of the thing me and this guy had
a wooden [__] Bowl I put the weed in
there weeds took two Puffs the [__]
whole plane smelled like weed wow they
were pissed two smoking marijuana on the
plane we're going to search didn't do
[__] I walked out of there with that
soldier saluting the cops and [__] yeah
got take a chance from time to time you
know for a soldier you got to bro i' get
a soldier High I [__] I get him doped
out of his brain if I had enough dope
for him they [__] press heavy duty
charges on you one night
theovon I got so [__] up in an airport
at 12 o of blow on me and that was
coming from New Jersey no do people from
New Jersey get busted for Coke more
often than other people you think I
[__] no I I was a [__] criminal
and I was I was living in I was living
in Asen and Coke was,
18800 an ounce right and I'm like are
you [__] people kidding me I'm paying
800 and they're [__] beautiful ounces
and I could cut it and still make money
I go [__] it so I started getting guns
and bringing them to the east coast and
started bringing Coke back but this was
the problem that I would take the 1:00
flight from uh New Jersey to Denver and
that's really 3:00 which would get me in
there like at 7 and it would start
snowing I still had to take a connecting
flight from Denver to Aspen that flight
would always get canceled here I am in
Denver airport with 12 ounces of blow
geeked out of my face at the [__] I
remember one night I was at the bar just
drinking [__] doing lines in the
bathroom and I kept putting the Coke in
a locker and I kept spending all my
money in quarters taking the coke out
and I became friends with a guy at the
bar me and him started snorting we got
[__] lit at 6:00 a.m. I've stayed in
the airport all night getting [__]
coked up jerking off in the men's stall
the [__] bathroom is dark and awesome
that is [__] yeah yeah dark dude
that's the dark side oh my God that's
the worst bro when you just up with your
[__] ideas feeling your [__]
pulse what's up lisad it's been a week
without an edible I know I'm just glad I
back from out of space I don't know if
you guys know I'm pretty high man oh no
[__] you we don't [__] around F my boy
joined Jiu-Jitsu two months ago three
months ago and he did his first [__]
tournament I've been going to jiujitsu
for two [__] years and I'm still
scared of going to the tournament Lee
went Saturday it's so much more fun than
practice third [__] place out of
three people so BR that's you know what
place I took no [__] place all right
I didn't I wasn't there I was walking
around a [__] Central Park with ducks
and there you are [__] choking
[__] my heart goes out to you
bro you're a bad [__] yeah
commendable bro you could have [__]
commendable bro you could end up in
fourth place you could have got
disqualified you couldn't have showed up
I I I was I I I had a little bit of a
like I have bronchitis right now so I
wanted to quit but I knew knew if I
didn't do it you John but and everyone
will kill me so I'll just go no we
wouldn't have killed you I understand
what was the match like the match I
wanted to see you play out the Handley I
see I'm not I was I was never scared of
it like I've said a wrestled in high
school was never good but I knew I
wasn't going to like physically die or
occasionally someone breaks an arm or
something but that's not even the end of
the world um it really I've been losing
weight for the past couple years and it
really kicked it into gear that I need
to finish losing the weight cuz I was I
was because it was a smaller tournament
I'm 228 right now I was going against
people who are like 290 280 so it was I
it wasn't it wasn't an ideal situation
for me were you pretty like were you
pretty
like did you smoke first no oh God
people ask me that man I I can't imagine
doing that smoke before jiujitsu it
makes her when Javier was choking me
that night and I was stoned out of my
mind I was like are you I was like I
just had to laugh it's a different world
is it oh could you be high and do it no
I tried a couple times I almost had
heart attacks damn because when you
start breathing heavy your mind takes
you away yeah so you know like when
you're on an edible and you breathe
heavy like when you're like when I go to
Jiu-Jitsu this morning I was breathing
heavy like I having a hard time yeah E
Yeah so if I would have done an edible
the edible takes your mind away and all
a sudden your mind the edible tells your
mind you're about to have a heart attack
and your [__] heart starts pounding
just from listening to your mind D not
even true sometimes just here I'll start
having like a little bit of a pation
sometimes yeah the Edibles let me tell
you some edibles don't aren't copasetic
for everybody man they create a lot of
anxiety a lot of people say you know I I
like smoking pot but for me it gives me
anxiety and it's not good for you it's
not good for you at all if you get that
uncomfortable feeling there's times we
eat [__] 8,000 milligrams of Edibles
and it's uncomfortable feeling you go
through an hour of like Jesus Christ
this is terrible I feel pretty right now
I feel pretty high do you really yeah
cuz I don't ever smoke so I feel [__]
when did you start comedy pretty high
man you've been around in that life for
like 10 years right yeah I started like
12 13 years ago okay cuz I know you were
that like you were really young like
2005 you were doing something I was
young man do you ever miss the weight do
you ever miss the weight bro I miss
eating what I want to eat yeah I miss
like I didn't care like how much would
you eat you just eat the [__] out of
something sometimes oh sounds nice man I
worked really yeah just [__] get what
you want put it in your mouth great it's
like even football like it's depressing
for me I don't watch football like I
used to watch football all day and I
would get a large pizza and 12 wings
[__] six Diet Cokes oh wow just great
and not even worry about it just not
even worrying about it at all did you
ever sleep on a [__] like piece of
crust or something like you were just
eating like a [__] monster not not
normally like we used to do this podcast
at 6:00 a.m. MH and I would work nights
yeah we used to we did it for like a
year for like at 6m at 6:00 a.m. and I
was working nights on a TV show so I'd
go from there to here and then I would
like it' be like 8: in the morning and
I'd be getting Jack in the Box damn and
like sometimes I would just pass out
from eating it well no just from all
these things but then I would pass out
but like the the rers would still be on
my couch or something it's terrible oh
okay cuz I never you never hear like
people's like [__] eating stories
everybody tells their weight lost story
like I want to hear when you was just
[__] hiding chocolate in your [__]
cheeks man when you just filling your
gills up I used to go I got I got I got
up to 315 that was the highest I ever
got yeah it at a certain point I was
every every night getting two packages
of ree sticks and two either uh Swedish
Fish or gummy bears and in my sticks
yeah oh those are the best are they good
those are still the best I can't have
them I can't have them but those are the
best and then either Swedish fresh or
gummy bears yeah and just have them and
I would tell myself I would have the
other I would have two of each the next
day but it would never happened wow so I
eat them all huh I miss that now I have
now I have a fudal and it's depressing
but still tastes it still tastes good
but it's not it covers the spread but L
what you really [__] want that's the
worst now you grew up where new uh
Louisiana how far from New Orleans a
suburb about 40 miles yeah 45 miles so
your family's eaters yeah family's like
we didn't eat a bunch of food but we ate
as much as we had pretty much I mean
I've had three experiences in New
Orleans yeah and one outside of New
Orleans
and all my experiences have always been
around food it's a very food culture
Foody culture and depending where the
[__] you go you know they'll hit you
with some alligator shrimp poboys shrimp
poboys like a [__] you know oh
they'll [__] when I went to shoot uh
Grudge Match we shot that New Orleans
but you know I was low man on the totem
pole and they put me in a hotel where
they give you all the meals are
inclusive yeah and at first I was like
I'm not going to [__] eatting a
[__] hotel oh my God the hotel food
was good every [__] meal was world
class and it was all like a seven cores
like start to finish salad dessert
appetizer you know everything was
[__] delicious so it's a food culture
so I mean you're in great shape you take
care of yourself yeah kind of I mean I
like do you eat what you want I mean you
have a great metabolism you work out a
lot not as much I wish yeah I work out a
pretty decent amount I wish that I
[__] start I wish I actually ate more
and like just like it would do like you
to just let like sometimes I just want
to honestly just
[__] fill myself with [__] food
and salt and [__] Su it's fun for a
little bit but it's I would give
anything to be as skinny as you are so
it's really yeah man I've never been
skinny so this is like a new a new thing
for me oh W so your whole life's [__]
feeling a little bit different on you
yeah I mean I'm still I'm still I'm 228
today so it's not it's not great but
it's better than 315 you didn't look fat
to me and I just thought like man this
guy like he's got kind of a unique shape
but he's chill but then I was like oh
and then if you feel fat that's a bum I
have well I don't I don't feel any
different at all but it's like I would
imagine I'm surprised you're not fat
like Ben like be are you serious I if I
lived in New Orleans and had beet and
trip [__] B I've never even had one
but I just see it and it just looks used
to be a place in Boulder baby formula
too actually down there baby formula you
see a lot of the sisters drinking baby
formula outside of the French
Quarter I don't know if you ever noticed
in a bottle what do they do huh in a
bottle no no no just can brother [__]
it just caning
up it's true man couple of sisters out
there can and up it's
uh you know it's weird you're talking
about this CU I think that like my best
eating period you know you start off
skinny you work out in high school you
play football you know I had a friend
that used to eat a box of [__] cereal
for breakfast and an Tim's cake how the
[__] that in a gallon of milk [__] the
milk is with the cereal was he driving
truck that's insane no he was in high
school he lift weights and and then you
know I was eating too I had a great
appetite then night I moved to Colorado
and they were they took away the night
eating there's no more drinking and
going to eat what I was used to eating
which was an open steak sandwich at 2:
in the morning with a f of cream of
turkey soup and not even brushing your
teeth [__] just going to bed with dirty
teeth [__] [__] son that's how I do it
[__] yeah [__] up so that's yeah
that's where I'm from and a place you go
to bed with dirty teeth you get dirty
teeth and you you know you don't uh I
don't eat here at night I go home if I'm
really high I'll eat whatever my wife
cooked which is controlled it's like a
chicken CET you know what I'm saying
like there not like 20 chicken cets well
it's 20 chicken cutet she could [__]
[__] up there'll be like one leftover
chicken cutlet I'll eat a chicken cutet
eat an apple you know what I'm saying
just it's crazy I've been lucky all week
my mom's been here for almost a week and
I haven't eaten this good in 4 years
making breakfast she hasn't we we've she
we've been sleeping a little late we she
a couple days she made breakfast but
it's been like she made brisket she made
uh a couple kinds of different kinds of
chicken and it just I like all of that
stacked all my like my entire fridge is
full now for like cob oh she made ice
box cake have you ever had that all you
do is you you take a layer of graham
crackers and you have to get the the
cook and serve pudding not like pudding
cups but you have to cook pudding and
you just do layers of pudding and gr
crack you put in the fridge and let
freeze up and then put some whipped
cream on it
m Paula's been talking about it for 3
days she loves it it's so good we sorry
interrad what you say we used to fill
[__] we used to have this game where
you would fill like people's two dudes
would fill their mouth with sugar you
know and then you would you you slap
each other in the [__] cheeks but
here's the thing
bro it's hard to hold a whole bunch of
sugar in your
mouth keep keep it all in well here's
the thing it starts dissolving but you
get parched because all your moisture is
going to this thing so your body starts
to dry out so then you start you're
you're basically holding the sugar uh in
your dry mouth at a certain point man
you feel like the desert how old are you
I don't know like he was a child okay
like when I was like eight like eight
yeah like yeah seven eight 11 14 even 14
even and this one 18yearold shi8 11
14 we have this [__] girl who's
probably 14 that went shirtless bro
since she was like [__] four four to
14 shirtless
bro shirtless why was that I don't know
it just their whole family was pretty
much shirtless and they didn't do any
different by the girls man this girl was
shirtless as [__] and we all thought
like damn she's like a long hair she's
like the most best looking dude you ever
seen right we thought that till about 11
and then somebody's like that's a girl
man she just go shirtless and we're like
and nobody told her to put a shirt out
in school or nothing oh I don't know
about school
but uh I never I mean she was in a
children's school I was a little bit
older than her but I never saw anybody
just be completely shirtless like that
there was who puts [__] sugar in that
mouth oh
yeah yeah [__] well it was a cheap
game bro it's like if you don't have a
bunch of money to go do something you
fill each other's mouth up with sugar
and then y'all just got to slap each
other in the cheek there was a kid in my
neighbor John Cony not a bad kid always
great sense of humor but he had a
brother Brian Connie in those days kids
didn't have ADD have autism you were
just [__] whether you had the [__]
eyes and yeah you just wasn't cutting it
[__] you just wasn't cutting it man and
they used to torture him yeah we called
him God's favorite we they used to make
him drink piss they piss in a beer
bottle and close it then put it at the
last bottle and he would take it can I
have a beer and he [__] drink it and
I was never involved this [__] with
Brian
Connie was he handicapped no he just
wasn't Sharp you know was he just wasn't
a sharp kid nice kid always said hello
Brian Cony but they did weird things to
him like they used to make him eat [__]
like they pay him like 15 bucks to make
him eat a lot of like weird stuff how
much [__] actual [__] no no no no like
fill his mouth with pepper and [__] like
that then they had this other kid the
the guy who they just fired from the
Miami Hurricanes defensive coordinator
when he was a kid his brothers and all
those guys neighbor used to tie him up
on a bicycle make him eat raw eggs and
blow him up in his mouth and all that
[__] like put the eggs on the shell and
smack him and blow the egg in his mouth
no wonder that my guy went to Penn State
was an all American Tax God I didn't I
would have died in your town there C I
was too nerdy for that I would have been
one of those kids the guy I got into it
with when I did that club before I met
Lee I did a club in New York City one of
the first times I went to New York to do
comedy on my own I booked a music Club
in the village right and I went there
and the guy that started a fight with me
his name was Brian Burns and when we
were kids when you were in grammar
school you he already had a legend what
he would do is he had a gang of guys
that would take you tie you down and
they would put duct tape on your balls
and [__] that glue [__] from taping
and they would call it a table oh they
would give you a table where they lay
you down and wrap you up with tape and
pull the tape off you and [__] like that
he was known for all that stuff for
spraying stuff on your balls he was a
big time bully and you know what happens
to bullies bro they get beat up later on
and like people and I remember that
night like I was like I could take this
[__] guy D and I had already a plan
he kept coming in to try to apologize
and I kept going you know what I could
take this guy I could kick him in the
[__] knee you could see he got to
like 300 something pounds he never
stopped eating so but you felt like so
it was crazy cuz the tide had switched
with that dude like in back in the day
he was a bully mean kid you know he was
bro when I was in eighth grade or
seventh grade he was already in high
school torturi resing people they said
if you play football be careful
because if something happened during
football practice that you hit him hard
or something he'd get his friends to
give you the table you know especially
if you were Spanish or something like
that you know oh that [__] got racial
huh it was what it was you know I mean
it was what it [__] was I mean we had
one Mexican kid that showed up on our
town we didn't have any Spanish people
we had one Mexican kid let me think
about what this kid's name was I think
it was Nick right and uh I remember we
all had uh science class and um oh
actually in science class had these
hamsters you could play with until the
second bell rang or whatever then you
had to give you know put them in the
cage and everybody could then we would
do learning you know and this [__]
one time they had this hamster right
Superman we named him and uh and I was
holding him in this [__] big
sweatshirt I had right and after class
uh I forgot he was in there he fell
asleep in a little pocket right where
you put your hands right so after class
I just throw my book bag I'm running
next you know I get in a fight with two
brothers right get beat up pretty good
and one of them had [__] killed this
hamster that was still in this pouch he
[__] and punched it so I never had it
like sometimes I'll be [__] I'm not
even joking bro I'll have dreams where I
feel like I had an
abortion poor Superman I knew something
wasn't going to be good I think his name
was Superman let me think for a second
it might not have been Superman why
would you take the [__] hamster out
of class and put them in your [__]
pocket for anyway no no because you was
sitting at class you just nothing to do
and it was nice to kind of have
something more now where' you go to high
school at mie oh not M next that town a
couple away from their college uh
Covington mandaville and where'd you go
to college I went to uh LSU and uh
University of New Orleans really mhm did
you graduate from LSU I graduated from
University of New Orleans eventually
look at you you bad [__] made it
when you went to LSU they still talk
about Pistol Pete M oh dude my the town
I grew up in here get the [__] out of
here he lived and died in our town dude
get the [__] out of here yep and Lee
Harvey Oswald went to um went to middle
school in our in our in our town get the
[__] out of here swear to god dude and I
mean I say this a lot but but in 19 uh
and once in the ' 80s and in 1994 a
bunch of infected monkeys got out
because tane University had their
primate testing facility Center in our
town and a bunch of infected monkeys got
out and they let us out of YMCA summer
camp to help the police look for them
bro I remember they came to summer camp
basically they sent kids to look for let
me get that pen real quick not kids dude
the tallest boys they took the tallest
boys right out and uh and we helped them
look for him I remember surrounding a
couple of chimps outside of a Kenny
Rogers roosters dude off a Highway 190
that's a true story dude that's the name
of your book huh I was surrounded some
chips and next to a Kenny Rogers roers
and dud the [__] got racial like people
would go around town they were yelling I
mean this is [__] up I mean this just
shows you how far in the South you are
people like 90 monkeys just escaped from
this place or whatever and you literally
have like you know people riding around
with guns [__] Confederate flags it's
like dude these are animals man like
relax like the [__] almost got it was
weird like people were like these
[__] monkeys like they planned it
like it was great like it was I just
threw that name out because today in
today's paper on Twitter it said that
the basball player from the Lakers is
producing A Pistol Pete marav
biopic and I'm sitting there going you
know what kills me about today is
they're doing
biopics about people that these
[__] don't even know that movie
should have been done two weeks after he
[__] died yeah but nobody thought
about doing it you know do you know
about pistol P I mean I think I know a
pretty good amount about him I mean I
know he played you know I know he played
at LSU I know he played uh for the
Jazz um I know his two sons really yeah
they played ball like whenever I was
growing up so one of them like a little
younger one of them a little bit older
so I mean they were Legends it was kind
of you know it was a small town like it
was Legends Legends yeah the biggest
name in [__] if he lost his father
wouldn't let him sleep in the house and
[__] or make him sleep in the [__]
yard this is Southern Basketball Jack
dude they had a half court or a quarter
Court in their upstairs of their house
above the look look in the Attic they
had a basketball [__] around the
marriages didn't [__] around that old
man didn't [__] around that dude D he
had like that's why he drank himself to
death Pistol Pete because he there was
no childhood his father made him go out
there and do wind Sprints and [__] yeah
and that guy wasn't fast but his [__]
handling skills were just phenomenal
made up for it in my life I've seen two
people handle a ball [__] phenomen
one was a guy named Pistol Pete marovich
who was an NBA
player and another guy was a kid
from South Carolina his name was Jackie
galloon white kid or black kid white kid
H and he played basketball on acid
that's why he didn't get drafted because
he was such a freak but his handling
skills I saw him play and I played
against him when I got older his
handling skills was so [__]
unbelievable what he could do with a
ball and unless you see that right it's
really hard to explain right even if you
see Kobe Bryant pass or whoever you know
Stephan Marbury pass it was nothing or
dribble or the control that Pistol Pete
had for a White Guy it's and he had a
tragic life I don't think he ever won a
championship I don't think he ever won a
championship I know like I think he
still has like the highest average per
game for college yeah yeah cuz he shot
90 times a [__] game his father would
the coach or something his father would
say [__] those four guys yeah literally
the [__] ball shoot the [__] those
four [__] I heard he even tried
to sometimes he would wear a completely
different Jersey like he would be on a
team and they'd have play in a team and
then he'd show up in a total different
Jersey and be like I'm going to play
both you guys and they be like you're
out of your [__]
mind it was nuts bro but uh yeah man we
got out to look for all types of chimps
that had gotten out of that uh out of
that joint you know you can still look
for it online they got some old stories
about you know it's crazy because they
had a lot of uh go on sorry no no I grew
up in New York City but in my heart
after I saw different places there was a
couple places I wish I would have grown
up one would have been New Orleans the
other would have been
Houston and there was one of the place I
wanted to grow up when I was a kid I
don't know why New Orleans I don't know
why I always thought New York would be
really cool you follow me like there's
always places like I'm very proud to be
from Jersey I love being from where I'm
from but it would be interesting like
when I go to New Orleans and I'm driving
around I always go hm how would I turned
out if I would have grown up on this
[__] Street well I don't know you but
I like I feel like the South get a bad
rap up North but when I was driving like
I drove across the country three times I
love the South everyone's nice it's it
has nice weather like I felt like I had
got a bad rap where I was in Mass people
are [__] I don't know people are
chill down there man but it's a lot of
the same like you hear you definitely
notice it's a lot of oldfashioned ideas
down there like people you know the
concepts are slow you know but that's
what makes the South the South right
listen that's what makes the South to
South I read somewhere that last week
when those guys the terrorists shot
those people uh that the neighbor said
he suspected something but he didn't
want to call the police because he
didn't want to seem racist yeah Jesus
Christ because he was too politically
correct you understand we we got a point
in our lives were too politically
correct look what happened yesterday
[__] Trump makes that announcement
against Muslims his [__] rating is
the highest it's ever been it's like 35%
he's 20 points ahead of the [__]
competition 19 points ahead of the
competition I like uh you like sleepy
black what's that I don't know Ben
Carson oh Jesus I can't vote so I don't
really know what you can't even vote no
I got felonies and I don't want to
[__] vote it's too much pressure then
you got to be responsible for your
[__] vote I don't have that type of
[__] conscience so if you get a
felony you don't have to vote 10 years
oh that's awesome years I don't I you
can't vote and you can't have a [__]
gun that's what they you know that's the
punishment they give you like really so
I can't vote and I can't have a [__]
gun I can see not having a gun but what
voting got to do it I was disappointed
but after I thought about voting I go
you know what it's too much pressure
it's too much pressure I don't know how
people just vote and move on with their
[__] lives voting for me is like
gambling if I would have voted on
[__] Obama I would have been pissed
off right now you follow me you're in a
corner at the [__] movie theater
because you voted for [__] Obama
that's what they should do to people
like if you make a bad vote you know you
voted for them take 50 people out of
each neighborhood and throw stones at
them you dumb [__] they're all liars
drown people them I don't I don't vote I
can't I I got in a big fight with my mom
and Paulo when they were here I I when
there's no popular vote I think it
doesn't matter at all especially like
where I grew up in Mass there's no if
you vote for a republican you're
throwing away your vote yeah and then it
just it doesn't make sense that the
popular vote isn't the way it elects
people and then even if it did they all
lie anyways so I don't I don't get the
point what would you do you think you
would addess like if you were a
politician you think feel like you so
long as I think about that like what I
[__] totally change the game and
we're like you know like a white beat or
some crazy boots or something you know
like if you were like so that think like
you know say if you was a governor or
something you'd be like I'm going wear
these crazy boots you know or I'm gonna
wear like a you know a [__] dope
jacket if I was a voting
American if I was a voting American if I
really was a voting
American you know I wouldn't give a [__]
about abortion that that's got nothing
to do with the price eggs I want to know
what you're going to do the country is
in this state of the country right now
what are you going to do to get us out
of this state let's go step by step for
your two terms let's go for the eight
years yeah give me the eight years how
it's going to pan out what are you going
to do the first year what are you going
to take care of what's second on the
agenda what's third do I give a [__]
about the homeless prom not [__]
really I there's a ton of [__]
problems we got to take in before we
worry about the minute little things
homeless people want to be [__]
homeless people what do you want me to
do a lot of them are doing fine a lot of
them are doing fine you see them over
here on the N of 134 getting changed
then they walk over to [__] Corvette
I'm driving a [__] Subaru hustling
like a [__] Savage taking two planes
a [__] week and these [__] are
getting changed making 40 Grand a year
at the end of the 134 you know I listen
man it's not the it's not the point I'm
talking about but that's I want to know
your plan I want to you plan step by
step by step by step how it applies to
me as an American I want you to plan it
out for [__] people who make $50,000
or less I want you to tell real people
real people you know and now you were
talking about the south and that they're
slower and that all that [__] you know
what I like that yeah I like that that's
there and the reason why it's there
there's a reason why a white guy would
say that he's going to stop Muslims from
coming in right now and people raise
their hand half of them that say oh we
it's cruel or whatever but the other
half are Americans that feel you know we
got to stop this somewhere oh yeah man I
think you got to shut it down bro I wish
if they had walls and you could press
the button right now I'd put them up
everywhere but it's not just it's not
just that it's you know look at the
[__] uh the the people the white dude
you know it's people who shut up the
movie theater let's not just blame one
[__] 100% we got to find out who's in
there I just want to know who my
neighbors are we all got to figure this
[__] out who's here listen man you said
it best yourself they're building
buildings and people moving in and out
they just said that these people have a
[__] passport duplication you don't
think they're here if you don't think
you're they billions on oil they have
everything it's just and I don't know
how what cuz what are they going to do
they're going to walk are they going to
go around now knocking on your neighbor
doors like Hey we're going to check all
the Muslims out you can't not even
Muslims but even just regular people you
know I don't really I don't pay too much
attention if Trump hadn't said the
things he said about Hispanics and this
stuff about the Muslims I think a lot
more people would be on board yeah I and
I actually read an article yesterday
that they're they're predicting that
Trump is going to bow out at the end
just like he did the last time so maybe
maybe he doesn't want too much support I
don't know right but it's just it's it's
crazy what people say and then and then
yeah if you lay out a plan right what
happens when they don't do any of what
they said yeah like I I voted the first
time for Obama and he said like the
whole thing like a 100 days I'll close
guantan that was like the first thing he
said and it's coming up on the end and
that's nowhere near being closed but
maybe he didn't know that he couldn't
close it I don't know but how do you
keep how do you hold him accountable you
can't it's CRA it's just like now let me
ask you something just for the argument
here cuz I don't know nothing about
nothing I'm a little high though you
politically I'm just making sure
everybody's H why was it important to
you that they would close wantan why is
that such no I'm not arguing with just
personally I I have no thoughts on that
but that was just the only thing I could
think of right now like that was he said
in the 100 days of coose I'll close it I
don't I don't know who if that's good or
bad I'm not now that people want them to
close gu time yeah why cuz it's the like
they're not giving them like Fair trials
they're just keeping them there I did
comedy there once did you for for the
troops are you not the prisoners
but um it was it was pretty it was
pretty fun I guess I mean I don't know
not for the I mean it's chilled on there
the chicks only had like seven chicks
not even that hot but uh some of the
guys seemed friendly and then we went
swimming and
everything we had a good time we had a
good time now what made you want to get
on stage um my dad was real old when I
was born that's how I how old was your
70 my dad was 70 hold on hold on one
second I got to go get a tissue you [__]
Tony's
better Oh I thought some [__] a little
no no no no I got just got to go blow my
nose but yeah I wonder what kind of hats
I would wear or special pants I would
wear if I was a president bro you ever
wonder of that man like American flag
pants
yeah yeah like a
little how's this how's the podcast
going I'm it's going good it's going
it's on right now huh I guess no we can
talk you stream yeah we're streaming
right now on YouTube that's [__] d
That's so your dad was 70 years old yeah
that's that's crazy how was that how was
it um was it was it it was pretty nuts
bro so wait who's high you're high I'm
very high okay Joy's high oh yeah Jo I'm
high I think most of the people listen
to do I seem super high you think no I
thought it was funny when you said like
going to do learning I think that oh
yeah man I get caught up sounding like a
[__] [__] sometimes I'm pretty I'm
pretty high though like if I think I'm
trying to think like say if somebody
like say if I wasn't myself and I came
up to me okay and I said that doesn't
make any sense and I
said hi [__] what were we talking about
what talking about yeah no it's
sometimes I wonder that like if I was
sober watching a high person would I be
able to know they were high dude I
wonder if you came up to yourself bro
would you even like who you are would
you be like look at this [__] right
here oh that's deeper than I was
thinking that's sometimes I think I try
to be what do you think me would you
like yourself honestly if you met
yourself dude being 100% And it's 100%
honest no I don't even like look I hate
when I do a movie and have to go watch
it or somebody makes me I'm dreading
watching this [__] special you know
I'm dreading all that [__] I don't want
to see me I don't want to [__] hear
me I don't want to see my body I don't
want to see my physique when is it when
is it special no we just cut we just
shot something in Vegas how was it
awesome it was what it was you know I
got to see it you know I just went
through the motions I I don't [__]
know it's good I'm really I'm too high
right now it's good earthquake oh is
that I hope no I I hope it is so your
dad had you when you were 70 yeah he was
was old how old was your mom 32 she she
was young your dad was slanging some
deck he was throwing it out there man
that was his first marriage no no he'd
been married a couple he'd been married
one time before maybe your dad still
alive before we talk about it no he'd be
old sorry it's all right appreciate it
man he'd uh he would be almost he'd be
106 106 I'm sorry I don't know you you
look like you're 22 so I'm all [__] up
I know you've been around here for 10
years maybe so he met you when you were
70 yeah he got old man he just uh I
don't know and that's sometimes on my
mom like when I think about my mom like
who would bang like a an old guy like
that'd be crazy I feel like what he was
he like an attractive man was he like he
yeah definitely handsome but he I mean
he didn't have any money you know what
I'm saying like who kind of thugs it out
with an old dude that many times let me
get back to how old was your dad when
they passed 86 so he was around till you
was 16 God bless you bro you got to have
him till you was 16 yeah that's a good
point yeah man it was so it was It was
kind of wild having like a old dad
because all the time you spent was just
like a little bunch of like kind of
vignettes of like like he would take me
to this bar sometimes with him bro and
you know the lady would give me [__]
chocolates right and then uh I mean one
night the lady I'm not even joking kept
giving me chocolates and my dad's like
no no more chocolates for me you know he
and i' had probably 30 bro like you
nothing could stop me from eating
chocolates bro I just continue to put
chocolates if they had chocolates around
me I would just continue to put them
into me and this lady my dad said no no
no and then the lady took me to the side
of the bar a little while later and just
gave me [__] T like almost like this
lady wanted to like poison me or
something you know so he used to take me
to do like weird [__] like that uh I
don't know God bless you bro no no no no
you [__] know you [__] know I lost
my father when I was three I lost my
mother when I was
16 so I that's crazy yeah so you know
some of the but right now I had my
daughter when I'm 49 every morning I
wake up I can't lie to none of you guys
I wake up I put my feet down I go God
thank you for me give me another day see
this little [__] girl all I want is
enough time just so I could give her the
[__] mentality of the church that's
all I need and let her work it out like
I worked it out without my mom that's
the best way to [__] do cuz I feel
like I'm going to die I did blow I going
die man you know God [__] knows you
get shot by one of these [__] monkeys
who knows yeah but you always uh you
always uh you know I always it's amazing
that now like I would say who the [__]
would have a kid at 50 yeah Don Johnson
had a at 52 and I did a movie with him
I'm looking at him going why would you
have a [__] kid yeah that's the most
selfish [__] thing in the world all a
I knocked my wife up so now you're
looking to live like you're like wait a
second you know I want to live for this
child right but [__] 70 your dad had
balls of steel brothers and sisters yeah
I got two younger sisters and an older
brother so we gotom and Dad same mom and
dad yeah oh [__] you got two younger
sisters yeah man we had a wild it was
yeah man it was pretty wild I mean I
guess I'm trying to think like more
about what it was like like I remember
like weird [__] I guess I mean I don't
know do I'm [__] high man um so I
remember like my dad would [__] he
let me drop like say as soon as I was
tall enough like 11 years old I remember
being 11 years old and my dad being like
uh hey will you drive me you know cuz he
couldn't turn his neck you know so like
he's like hey will you drive me and I'm
like yeah I'll [__] drive I'll hit
like 510 I a little gross spur when I
was 11 so next you know I was driving my
dad places dude like I remember we
driving at the post off and he said go
around the block and uh I went around
the block and [__] hid like seven
cars bro just [__] SED my dad had a
cutless like a Delta 88 you know like a
just straight up [__] rig Rider bro
and um and I was just and it was a piece
of [__] it was all banged up and I would
just go around the block and then one
time he let me drivve on the interstate
uh I was doing like 70 80 miles an hour
driving to Hammond and it's probably
about like 30 Mi and my dad's just fast
asleep in the [__] passenger side son
so those are the [__] good old days
man what what I feel from you a little
bit like when you tell me the stories
you're happy you miss them and
everything but are these stories weird
to tell sometimes like are they weird to
tell yeah a little bit I mean it's not
the normal American family like me I
have the same family right so I could
see that we both share that same little
twitch because as you get older you'll
appreciate those stories more cuz nobody
[__] had a life like that when your
dad when you're were 11 your dad's like
drive the [__] car yeah you know
that's cool as [__] we were all begging
to drive the car you're begging to drive
the [__] car at that age it's a small
City you know cops knew each other you
got pulled over 30 [__] years in
those days you but just the fact
that sometimes when your parents give
you a lot of trust it does something to
you it's good and it's bad right you
know like you had an older dad that he
saw life at what it was at 70 and I bet
now when you tell those stories
sometimes s you're like ah should I even
say the story let me tell you something
theovon you have no idea how lucky you
are you know how you don't have no idea
that you had this life cuz most kids
can't even imagine that [__] right most
kids have to steal a car at 16 you know
it this so many good points of growing
up no matter how you grow up as long as
your parents were around just having a
life is great I know it's tough people
get adopted and they get stabbed and
they get beat up and [__] you know I'm
very lucky when my parents Thugs and
Muppets man yeah when my mom died I
didn't have to go into the system you
know I was old enough to make my own
decision it's so weird till today I
realized I didn't even do paperwork when
my mom died my friend said you want to
live with us I'm like yeah that was it I
kept going to high school like nothing I
just switched my address and that was
nobody asked any questions who's your
legal guardian me that was my legal
[__] Guardian me those are the
[__] days D I feel like I feel like
kids can't have anything like that
anymore like all the I don't know it was
just this
Ambiance um I think before some of the
technology we have now that just made
everything [__] dope one of the
reasons why I wanted to go home with my
wife and the baby
was because of my paranoia of dying I
wanted to walk my daughter up and down
the same streets I walked so I parked
the car I walked up giv a Terrace I
walked down Union Turnpike but the best
walk we did was in the park where I used
to play basketball yeah it was open I
took her in the park and now they
replace a Hut there used to be a Hut in
there and one of the most racist things
I ever heard come out of a person's
mouth was in that [__] Hut that me
and everybody in the park looked at each
other and just kept [__] shaking our
heads there used to be a Hut there and
the guy's name was Mr kennel uhuh his
two sons are still alive with the one
son's still alive nice kid I always like
Jackie isn't it this has to be 1975
uhhuh we're in this park and what just
playing tag whatever the [__] you play
when you're 11 or 12 there was a
basketball court but in those days we
weren't allowed on the basketball court
the older kids were drunk unless they
picked you you couldn't [__] so we
just played whatever and the monkey bars
and [__] chill and that Hut was there
and it was the summertime MH and I'll
never forget that Mr kennel was in that
Hut and there was you know he was coming
in there no he was sitting in there with
a fan on him in this little Hut and the
window is slide open and he's sitting
there he's got his glasses on Mr
kennel's got to be 40 right and there's
eight Spanish kids 20 Italian kids you
know six Irish kids and one fat black
girl blowing with a huge no no with a
huge Julius Irving afro she's a little
kid right she's got to be T she's just
she's throwing rocks at the kids they're
all throwing rocks at each other they're
all having a good time and all of a
sudden out of nowhere one of the white
kids spits at Marlo
and Maro spits back at the white kid and
Mr kennel sees this now we're over here
I don't know what the [__] we're doing
he sees this and he slides open the
window and he pops his out the window
goes hey don't let that [__] spit get
on
you right this is
1975 he goes that shit'll go right
through you and he closed the window and
me and the other kids sat there and
looked at each other like we had never
heard like I heard [__] on a Richard
PRI album like that was it for him to
that was the most ra and Marlo just kept
spitting at the white kid like nothing
happened Marlo didn't give a
[__] damn man ah that ISU well that Hut
is gone my point is the Hut and its
racism is gone right they had this uh
kid that lived down the street from us
named Boogie and uh the dad was like a
bus driver in our town and um and he
used to cut our hair right and uh he's a
bus driver that cut cut hair yeah he was
he was a bu driver the cut hair and here
the crazy part I me think about this the
only haircut he knew how to give was his
own cut right like the whole like the
style he had right and it was it was a
[__] it wasn't even a style it just
looked like [__] right so all the boys
and most of the girls had the same cut
in our town man everybody looked jacked
up but what were we talking about black
people oh no no no no uh the the priest
yell that [__] man the first time I want
to go to New Orleans was when I read
about [__] the mafia down there MH
and how that guy ran the mob and how
everybody thought that that whole Kelly
assassination came out of New
Orleans it was also very interesting to
me then I saw a movie
called with Richard Gear and Kim
Bassinger Fatal Attraction no fatal
[__] attraction that's a chick that
shows a [__] oh that's uh I know it is
Sharon Stone right this is what if
Sigourney Weaver showed her [__] would
you look or not [__] yeah with that over
oh I love that sexy over no mercy no
mercy was a movie that came out in 1987
about white6 86 about white
[__] killing each other in New
Orleans and the guy that was her
boyfriend bought her mhm bought her like
that Happ was in New Orleans he bought
her from her mama right he raised and
they P her woy Allen [__] her she was
beautiful Kim Bassinger you imagine
buying Kim bash when she's like 13
cheaper then and just
feeding feeding her steaks and [__]
fattening her up when she's 18 you give
her a stabbing you marry her she don't
know no difference you hide her from the
world what time is it I have no [__]
idea it's been 1982 for days you know
what I'm saying don't ask do you think
we all come from incest really when you
really think about it like well from a
[__] Island oh then you have to have
probably have there's incest I know for
a fact that my grandmother and my
grandfather like third cousins or
something like that so there's got to be
I'm [__] for from bloodstream you
know what I'm saying something along I
know something happened my uncle told me
for the first time he said something
wasn't right no he told me because you
know that your great great grandmother
and your great-grandfather were like
third [__] Cousins or something
that's why the maiden name is kind of
weird it's Valdez malarz or some [__]
they just dropped the malarz or some
[__] so it's an island when you you come
from a [__] Island there's got to be
incest somewhere along the line I don't
think I'd ever do incest man even if I
think I had the hottest hottest family
member ever bro ever think about that
though dude say cousin listen I don't
want to talk about incest on the church
though we got [__] boundaries here we
can't be talking about incest I had a
cousin I wanted to [__] too as a kid
what I'm saying I ain't lie nobody I
ain't going to [__] nobody I thought
you just said we couldn't talk about
it when I was a kid I had sex with like
Puerto Rican cousins that like like your
families grew up together but you're not
really blood and they're like you guys
are cousins or some families encourage
it you guys should hook up it be a nice
wedding I had sex with a little girl
that that that that she wasn't a little
girl she had hair I didn't Wow first
Eevee Eevee was her name and she was
older than me by a year and I used to
sleep oh one day she goes look at it and
I looked at her almost [__] died my
hair on it I sniffed it dang you got
down there I young fell no I didn't eat
it I just sniffed it I think and I
[__] ran away yeah that first smell
is pretty strong it's a real uh I don't
remember why you got to talk about
smells for it's Monday I don't know my
bad is it Monday [__] Thursday what
is it l THS Lis say's got to go back to
his house stoned to the Gill hope to God
my mom's asleep why she not going to be
because look how high I am because you
told you'll probably be fine man you
should bring her half a jointly and just
tell her how it's going to go down
tonight yeah why don't you [__] do
some C my god get [__] Wicked cuz I'm
not you're going to argue with her
anyway just no she knows bring home a
half a BM light that Savage right in the
living room yeah no as I as I was
leaving she was like do you want me to
freeze the food cuz she made me a whole
bunch of food wow and I was like you
know what everything we had tonight just
leave it out cuz I'm going to want to
eat that when I get home it she like the
whole like the whole breast I was like
yeah the whole another breast damn so I
uh I'm trying to think of what I was
going to say man what were we talking
about what made you jump on a [__]
stage what made you jump on a stage the
first time oh yeah I don't know man I
just thought I guess tell making people
laugh was just the funniest that was the
best thing like if people weren't
laughing I was like what the [__] are we
doing we're just doing all this other
[__] and then we wait for and then
rarely somebody says something funny and
we laugh like why don't we do a little
bit of the inverse you know like we do
all this other [__] the best part is
when somebody's laughing so was your dad
funny he was pretty funny man uh where
was he from he was from uh Nicaragua
Nicaragua no
wonder oh Jesus Christ no wonder he was
slinging dick at 70 you should have made
when I thought he was a white dude I was
like okay he's are crazy I thought he
was like somebody from uh you know like
one of those guys in the
South just get over here I'm GNA [__]
you right now I don't give a [__] that
you dirty too lot of rep little rep now
you now you listen Filipinos and those
Spanish dudes they got sperm eggs and
that nut to their [__] 90 I swear to
God they'll start a kid like a
magician those [__] old SPS and those
[__] Filipinos Janice my my
daughter's godmother yeah her father had
a kid at 74 yeah why did you just pull
out 40y old woman 70 [__] dude they
could do Seaman into a pond and it would
start up at some point man they are so
but then I watch that movie with Alec
Bal one and the young chick yeah and he
was at a fertility clinic with a bunch
of other [__] dudes
like 50 old Dayton 20 year old what is
that it's uh it's complicated yeah yeah
man I remember oh Puerto Ricans you were
talking that they used to say uh that's
when did you guys oh I was talking about
the first Mexican kid we had in our town
right so we had class with the hamsters
right going back to that right the the
that man Mr Mr Blackwell's class we had
the hamsters they let you keep the
hamsters after Superman got killed no no
no that was it I just meaning it was
that same time bro everybody would get a
different pet
we used to play this game where you
would like somebody would lay down and
you would put a snake on their back or a
fake snake on their back right and you
would play guess if I have a snake on my
back or not right and people would
literally bet uh if they did or what
they were going to guess and then
sometimes we put this game where you cuz
they had this one rabbit in there that
was always falling asleep it was like
almost hey you know like a whatever
rabbit narcolepsy kind of is you know
where he just drifts off you know cuz
it's a rabbit they're not doing much you
know and you would set a rabbit on a
pile of money and you try to pull the
dollars out from under him and uh and
without waking him up that was like the
biggest uh thing we used to do in class
before class but the problem but the not
the problem but the thing that happened
was this Mexican kid moved in named Nick
right and the first thing he ever said
in class the M was uh in science they
also taught you sex ed right so like the
first day this kid Nick was in there was
during the sex ed part and he stands up
and he goes uh what he goes what do pop
that cherry mean that's what he said
he has the [__] teacher like a
serious his could be like who just pop
that cherry mean and then he uh he ended
up banging some girl like in sixth grade
right and uh and she broke up with him
broke his heart and he he started like
rap music and he wore this t-shirt that
said Nick the rapper that he wrote on it
with a marker right but he only put one
p in it and it said Nick the Raper on it
the [__] shirt that he wore and they
[__] expelled him they expelled him
that's
racism uh I guess he was Mexican but see
Mexican didn't play a part in it he was
a bad speller and he [__] was asking
stupid questions what does pop that
cherry mean pop that cherry remember
that saying you don't hear that anymore
dude you never hear that never hear that
[__] got I bet her Cherry's been popped
you could tell if you look at her watch
how she walks I never I never popped
anyone's Cherry you didn't n you still
out there though man you married no
almost n you're not bro you'll get a
little bit of [__] trm that's [__]
never been anywhere I don't know that's
a lot of pressure dude I'll tell you
this more pressure than voting buddy of
mine okay first time my buddy got some
trim right uh we were at this dance and
my buddy ended up you know touching this
G's vagina after the deal after the
dance and we uh all were sitting around
this fire at his at his house later and
uh so he's like you know telling
everybody what happened and my buddy's
dad came out right and heard it and kept
smelling my buddy's fingers then I
always standing out by the fire dude for
probably like 40
minutes is that [__] nuts how
terrible would that be
you you be rubbing your pants what would
you do norly right and then the same
night bro I was sleep in this guy's room
and he had a bunch of pets stacked up
along the walls because he loved all
kinds of pets and where's five of us
sharing a bed right and um and all night
bro I can't sleep right cuz I'm SC I'm
scared of all these animals bro I'm
scared all these animals bro and I can't
sleep right and so uh I'm just thankful
that this one this dog keeps barking man
I'm so high that this this dog I'm just
thankful that this dog outside the
window keeps barking I'm like cuz I'm
awake I can't sleep right all the other
four kids in his bed are asleep and you
can just hear these pets moving in her
cages and he had a big ceiling fan in
the middle of the room that was spinning
right so it's like whirling up all these
pets right and even though we can sleep
is keeping them awake cuz you got to
think a ceiling fan for a pet that's got
to be like you know [__] tornado
going off constantly right we don't
think about that you know so I'm [__]
laying in the bed thankfully this dog
barks every now and then it keeps me
company right even though it's outside
and then you hear Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom my buddy's dad walked out there
killed the dog right outside the [__]
window
boom went back to sleep dude same dude
that hours earlier had been smelling a
young man's hand man same man and that's
what blew my mind about the world like
how could at one moment a guy be so
gentle that dude's a moner yeah and then
7 hours later be blowing up freaking
animal's head open cuz it was barking
you know you have an animal in the woods
bro it's going to bark you know how much
Woods is out there you know he probably
hears everything they say they can hear
everything imagine hearing six times
something you'd [__] be angry you
know your neighbor you know four houses
over I don't know man I'm high bro first
you talk about incest you got talk about
killing dogs you got to bring me down
sorry I'm I bring you down I'm in that
down [__] dog I'm sorry
since Lee told me his girlfriend don't
do
laundry damn I haven't been that [__]
depressed how you going to get the
laundry done dude she doesn't live with
me why would you do my laundry I do my I
did my laundry I didn't bring it to the
thing and bro it's if you're really in
love with her you should [__] leave a
load over there when you go back 2 days
later see if it's cleaned or not her mom
love no but the thing is she still lives
with her mom her mom would do it oh wow
her mom has offered [__] yeah bring it
over there fold the on these put starch
on them is her Mom married to a brother
or not have you ever had [__] she's
Mexican have you ever had underwear star
underwear no that's sounds terrible why
would you want to start [__]
tremendous make you feel like an adult
soft [__] makes you feel like you have a
checkbook you know it makes you [__]
feel good that's what I miss Bro Look at
[__] Lee you got to go into the house
now how you going to act Nick the Raper
good Nick the rapper and [__] oh my God
so what was the first place you got on
stage uh this place called Brown uh this
place called Brown in uh down in
Louisiana it was a bar down there and
then I went on this thing called
semester at C which was like a
university like a floating school that
goes like you literally circumnavigate
the globe when I was in college and they
had uh they had an open mic on there and
they they had a senior passenger on our
cruise ship that had died right so they
was keeping him in the freezer right so
I just made some jokes about you know
like different like you know cold cuts
and [__] you like this sandwich tastes
like Berry you know and just vague [__]
like that and kids you know kids were
kind of laughing and so then I got up uh
they had like an open mic thing on there
and I got up on there and it was pretty
it was fun you know joking for a NIC
looking kid you're a dark dude and I
like that about you on stage you take
people in a weird Direction and I look
at you and I go this [__] kid you
know I trust him with my [__] animals
thanks man well not that one shoot
[__] dogs and you [__] well a
couple Brothers beat that animal up I
never did that super uh Superman I never
did that that was there you know to be
honest couple of Brothers I killed the
[__] rat a couple times I actually
backed over a deer once with a [__]
lawn mower if we're really going to
share stories I swear to God man it was
a big bush hog and I used to work on
this Farm in the summertimes right and
this man let me cut the grass with a
huge bush hog so one day I'm just
cutting and I backed around to turn it
around and a
[__] deer man ran over a deer with it
actually ended up killing a deer damn
this
dark j a deer jumped at my car once
there you go you killed it didn't no it
ran away you probably killed it though
did you hit it yeah but I was going like
20 I was going 20 M hour you hit it and
that's 20 M an hour dog you know how
fast that is well yeah that's true dog I
had a dog in worshire oh no 10 years ago
coming home not Stone minding my own
business wow doing the speed limit you
know you're on [__] Wilshire
Boulevard yeah you know no I wasn't even
on Wilshire I was on that block that you
cut from Olympic all the way up to
sunset on the other side for one of
those that deep one and all of a sudden
[__] a dog I didn't hit him straight
up he he ran into my car and he bounced
off my car and got in more shock and he
was limping and cars were going around
him and I pulled over and I tried to get
him but he he ran that mother once you
hit them they [__] run they run
forever you feel terrible I mean you
feel [__] horrible whether it's a
squirrel or whatever you feel [__]
terrible you know but but on a happy
note accidents happened I had a great
time looking at your cats I had a great
time watching your cats week I know you
did thank you very much so much fun my
cats are good [__] animals man I
never had a cat man really you had dogs
I'm ready yeah you're ready no we didn't
have a dog but I'm thinking about
getting a dog I've been thinking about
it I'm still considering it if I didn't
have as many allergies as I do I would
get cats cuz like it was funny like they
have like little setups like gry would
sit right at the edge of your kitchen
and wait for somebody and like attack
him like get bye hilarious H like I
would pause the TV and start watching
him and Demi runs into her [__] so Demi
will go [__] with somebody else somebody
else will SWAT him he'll give him a look
and go [__] you and all walk right into
gray and gray will hit him with three
quick rights to the head and he'll go
[__] you dirty [__] and then he'll go
in the kitchen like nope [__] these
[__] are crazy [__] it's a show to
watch
animals whether they're dogs or cats
especially at night when you have one or
two or three of them day and gray went
crazy for the ham she wasn't stop me I
told you they should have a cat like uh
do they have like a streaming cat
Channel where you can just watch cats
whenever you want we should get you oh
that's what we should do we should get
an iPad and per like put it up and like
Periscope the cats yeah that's what I
want to do you should start a cat Town
dude and dress them up like different
[__] uh ethnicities so when they show
up and interact you could like it's
almost like a game of Risk N I don't
like when people dress up their [__]
dogs and [__] yeah I don't know why they
do that huge industry there's no dog
that wants to have a [__] one oh they
had a kid uh in our town and this is no
correlation but that had really bad like
kind of I don't think it was down
syndrome but something pretty close and
his mom would dress him up constantly
like dress him up like oh God like in
like almost like costumes all the time
like he's in a pirate costume like this
week like his mom like he was like like
it was always Halloween or something for
him you know you're a crazy young man
that's why I love a about give some
shout outs he's like yeah he's a panther
you know
I want to give a shout out happy
anniversary to Tina and Jimmy Joe Aiden
Diaz Jesse Bryant Peter Mandy bar Jim
Jorgenson Paul Lynch Jack brater what's
happening you bad MMA [__] and
my man Henry salari you better show up
to class this week
[__] and Dustin Zaki just had a
baby Dustin Zacky had a baby yeah yeah
yeah a lot of [__] things going on in
the church [__] world good energy oh
and one and one quick thing Steve Simone
is doing a
GoFundMe did you hear about that I heard
that something like that he's doing he
there's a bunch of great uh he's doing
great things for a couple families and
kids and wants to do more for people at
Children's Hospital in La uh so Bill bur
retweeted it and I'll tweeted tonight it
just he's uh giving some kids who have
some pretty terrible diseases like some
happy times on during the holidays
that's awesome Ste Simone's a good
[__] great heart man he's over there
giving blood bringing sandwiches
he plays with the kids listen man it's
it means the world of people when you
visit him yeah he's exceptional man that
guy's got a million Hearts bro good dude
you know uh it's really weird we live in
a place where people do weird things you
know like people do weird things to get
attention you know and if you know
anything about Steve Simone he does
everything from the heart yeah with good
intentions you know 100% he's uh he's
one of those dudes that's in La that you
you happy to be his friend he keeps you
grounded yeah yeah especially if you
come from a society that's not selling
their [__] blood in this town to get
ahead you know what I'm saying like
there's people in this town that you
know who they are they come up to you
they talk to you they don't give a [__]
about you man yeah when you start making
money all sudden you're the best thing
in the world they're there with their
hand out telling you how they helped you
we always believed in you you know where
were you when I was living in that one
bedroom apartment and you wouldn't take
my call yeah but you have to put it all
into perspective but there's a there's a
certain element in this town that you
look at and when the coke finishes
they're going to be gone they gone and
then there's a certain element in this
town that when the coke finishes that's
when they become your friends and Steve
Simone is one of those dudes you know
it's really uh he brightens your day he
has old school Val he had lunch with me
and my mom yesterday we went to Domingos
unbelievable he has a lot of old school
values that you look at we went to eat
last week uh we got to we got to New
York Thursday night we didn't do much
uh we got to New York about 5 then
Friday we started our [__] Jaun and
Friday night we went to Rudy's did you
ever go to Rudy's with meari place and
stuff it's been there since 19 [__]
70 MH and when I was in high school they
used to serve me and they have squid and
that's what they're known for Statewide
like people go in there 24 hours a day
Rudy squid muscles with red sauce you
got mad at me cuz I was too nervous to
buy something expensive so I got ravioli
like Dam and it was still still
delicious it was amazing it was amazing
everything there amazing but we were
eating and my I could see something my
wife and I asked her what what's going
on and she goes you know I don't see
this in
La like people are having a conversation
nobody's looking at their phone yeah
guess what happened last week guys you
ready for this a girl who I [__] with on
Facebook uhhuh Hi how are you she was
sitting at the table next to us me and
my wife sat there and I go Terry this
girl in the table over here on this date
I [__] with her on Facebook watch this
and when she went to the bathroom she
came back I go and she was like oh my
God I saw a post that you were in a park
with the baby I didn't know you were in
Cliff it was [__] amazing like what
are the chances Clifton Cliffside
Cliffside Park is where this place is at
and then I saw somebody you're going to
love this story then I saw this girl
Joyce and I saw her and I go what's
happening she goes oh my God how are you
and the guy she was with like I knew her
30 years ago when she was married but
they break up and now she's dating she's
dating a kid named Mikey Moore that was
one of those kids in the neighborhood
that you always bumped into at 2 in the
morning right like if you bumped into
Mikey Moore you were on to something
right Mikey Moore had a few bumps he
knew where it was a few bumps he might
have a valum but he was always solid
like Mikey Moore is solid but it's he
had a lot of claim to fam like Mikey MO
was one of those guys that people
underrated yeah and he'd light some
[__] up from time to time like
one time we robbed a Chinese restaurant
deliver guy we just took his [__] C
dog first of all they got we called the
delivery to the park okay you show up at
the park how do you say that to deliver
it to the park can you [__] believe
that that's great they said deliver it
to a they they deliver it to next to the
park and when the guy came we [__]
bum rushed him we took the car
but listen to this Mikey Moore delivered
the Chinese food and kept the and came
back and gave me a little taste of the
viig you understand me after he dumped
the [__] car cleaned it off of Prince
the guy got hit in the head with like a
bowling
pin who the [__] robbed somebody with a
bow can you [__] believe that's gangs
it was next to this park this place this
this North Bergen is known for all these
little Parks like 51st Street Park and
and each Park had a different person
personality a different person
represented that Park like 64 Street
field they were deep into [__] drugs
and booze and [__] ACDC and [__]
music and and they fought and you know
they played football and they were heads
but they [__] fought you know 88
Street had more of a little that that
Park had a couple dabblings of heroin up
there Arts no well no there was no artsy
there dog you know I was telling
somebody my neighborhood stores were the
SPI store and the [__] store the dragon
grocery was owned by a Chinese Cuban guy
that was the [__] store and the Cuban
place was the SPI store and that was how
artsy that was there was no Art District
it was the [__] neighborhood the black
neighborhood the [__] spck
neighborhood that's hilarious yeah
that's it man in the south is just like
that black and I you know it's just
black and white though that's the crazy
thing in our town is just black and
white that's what I would love about
maybe like New York and New Jersey just
seem like you have so many types of
people around there that must have been
awesome so what made you wake up and say
Los Angeles anybody call you yeah I had
a buddy actually I uh I had a buddy who
was like uh come help me move right he
lived out in San Francisco so I was like
all right oh no he's like come out and
hang out with me one weekend so I got a
plane ticket came out to meet him right
when I get there he's like I'm moving
and I'm like what the [__] do you know I
was coming in this weekend right he's
like n man I'm moving uh down to LA and
so I just went with him and then I just
stayed for a while back and forth and
stayed get you bro it's kind of like
this thing here I don't think I'll stay
forever oh I miss it every day man
really still 10 years here you how many
times a year you go back yeah probably
four times a year two planes to go back
uh one one plane to go back you drive
the 40 miles uh yeah then I drive get a
rental car um I got nieces and nephews
now I actually had a niece that was just
born uh like less than 24 hours ago a
little girl so congratulations thanks
man yeah I'm pretty excited uh Stella
Blue that's her name so but yeah it's a
chill place man good family good to go
home you know I love going home uh I had
you on the show for a reason theovon I
just don't put [__] anybody from the
store on the show anybody like that I
like your work ethic you know I think
you're a solid guy um when I got to the
store I noticed something that the older
guys were dicks yeah they were real
dicks first week at the store I got into
a fist fight did you really first week
dog this this last time back no no no no
no no no no 199 [__] 7 I get past
February [__] 19th wow by February
24th I'm already in a pushing match SL
Fister cups in front of The Comedy Store
what saves me is mit's getting out of
her car and she goes what's going on
guys and she sees me and she sees the
other guy on the floor and she looks at
me and she smiles so she knew what time
it was my first week is a regular here I
don't [__] around right
so I had I thought about you today and I
thought about I was having you on and I
I look at a lot of the guys at The
Comedy Store I give the utmost respect
because for me to be a better comic I
have to be a better gentleman to you
young guys what makes me what's going to
make me a great [__] comic is the
love I give to you young guys not what I
can pass on I can't pass on nothing to
you but addiction and
chyia and a bad [__] fungi toe what
you could learn from me is what I didn't
do and what didn't do but the love I
give you guys is the better I get as a
comedian and I know this because those
guys that used to [__] hate on me
boom they're
gone they're gone I don't even think
Facebook's lets some on right they're
gone you know they're gone and they were
miserable at the end they sat there and
they sneered instead of sitting there
and being supportive and getting that
young guy a hug I don't go on stage I go
on stage to do my [__] act Theo
and when I see you back there you have
my utmost respect cuz you could have
canceled or Faked an injury or done
whatever and you go back there and you
[__] go up there and go give it for
Joey and you [__] bang it I watched
you yeah don't think I don't watch it
yeah so I want you to understand where
I'm [__] coming from D I got into a
beef I remember one time theovon what
the [__] would you do if I said come
into the
stage there's nothing good to say about
this guy Theo Von what would you do to
me on stage you know I I didn't do
anything I didn't do I think I didn't
want to go at that realm even at that
youth and comedy even it's crazy and
coked up the [__] Indian as I was
something at that moment but till this
day I hate that guy and I don't see him
ever again damn I won't see another
store comic another store comic yeah
like those older guys I was there the
night when this older comic went at Joe
Rogan on the main room he brought Joe up
and he insulted Joe and Joe said
something to him and they had a stop the
show they were going to Duke it out in
the [__] main room over what over the
intro the guy gave it was listen man the
guy moved to town and a year later he's
making 30 grand Lee you're here 20
[__] years still getting the 1240
spot in the main room once a month what
are you going to [__] feel like and
all a sudden this young kid comes that's
dirty and he's on an NBC show meanwhile
they've been telling you to [__] work
clean get a trumpet and uh you know and
all of a sudden this young kid along and
I learned from instead of hating on the
young guys I learn from you [__] guys
you guys keep me current I sit there
sometimes and [__] and I'm talking
about not Sebastian Sebastian's
established B is established I'm talking
about you and sanis and the [__]
other guys and these are all young guys
those people after midnight I've been
there I [__] been there where it's 12
[__] 45 and everybody went over now
it's 1:10 and you got a 1015 at BC yeah
you follow me and there you are going
[__] but you stay so the only way to me
to become better is to be listen if I
want to be a mentor I go back to prison
right and help Momos get their GS okay I
can't Mentor nobody I'm not here to
Mentor nobody I'm not going to lie to
you sit here and give you notes every
who the [__] am I to give you [__]
notes these Comics the [__] am I give
you notes all I could do is hug you and
go you're a bad mother [__] keep
[__] these [__] up yeah
that's all you could do and I think you
become I learned this the last two years
at the store really because I've become
a better comic because I'm sitting I
went to the you know I go out and see
these young comics and they would
inspire me yeah when you're getting
older you see these young guys and
you're like godamn I got to pick my
[__] game up I got that's a
good attitude man you got to go back to
training camp these young [__]
ain't [__] around and then I
backtrack I go home and smoke joint like
ah I remember when Joey Diaz used to dot
his te's whatever dot his eyes and you
know what I'm saying and top his teeth
you do man that's do
you that's [__] just I mean I don't
even know man that's nuts so always
remember like I know what to say me that
that store is our [__] home if you
could go back in time though Joey
starting if you go back in time do you
think were you the same way a long time
ago or you say you just feel like you
learn this really now
like do you feel like you were always
like that cuz sometimes I feel like I
it's hard to get the negative [__] out
of your head in this town you know I had
nothing going on why would somebody hate
on me I wasn't good-look I was long in
the toot I had nothing I had no agent I
had nothing going on the only person who
gave me any [__] love was Mitsy Shaw
yeah that was it and these old guys
would sit there they'd get there at 5:
after 9 Theo even if they didn't have a
spot they'd sit there and they'd sign up
for that [__] list and they lurk all
night wow and when you pulled up you
could see like all six of them go [__]
you know like they would beg for you not
to show up so they could do their 15
minutes and get that that glory for
those 15 minutes they would sell their
soul they would wish a heart attack on
you so you could get up and do your you
know it was just a horrible feeling you
know what I'm saying I remember I had
surgery one of the reasons I stopped
going to the store was I had a fat ball
in my neck and it kept getting bigger
every time I got every time I got
excited it was the funniest thing it
would come out of here and it would just
throb out of my [__] neck it was a
fat ball and I finally got the balls and
I went down and it wasn't cancer it was
just it was just a fat ball think of fat
and the doctor had to slice my neck and
stick his hand down there and take this
fat ball out and he showed it to me in a
jar and I'll never forget what the first
thing I thought when I looked at that
fat ball I thought about all the people
that came up to me at the store I don't
know why man right there in that
operating table when when I'm coming out
of my anesthesia I'm talking to my wife
and he comes over he goes you want to
see the fat ball we took out and when he
showed it to
me first thing I thought about was all
the people at the store that shake your
hand and you turn around like [__] him
you know I thought about all those
people hey congratulations on Spider-Man
too [__] cokehead right and you feel
it you know who's not on your team yeah
and you go home and 20 years ago I would
come down off my Coke and actually go to
their house and knock on door and say
what the [__] was your problem last
night D but as I got older I thought
about damn I thought
about why would they act that way I
can't lie to you when I got here guys I
was jealous of people from 97 till like
98 and a half then I figured it out if I
stopped being jealous I could take that
energy and do something good with it
yeah you were jealous of the what they
got that energy it's basically adjusting
that energy it's not a jealousy of a
specific human being it was a jealousy
of how the F Dio how the [__] did you
get Innovative I was in the belly room
one night 11:30 and the [__] guy came
up to me what the [__] are you talking
about I'm here all the [__] time and
nobody says boo to me you're here at the
[__] belly room on a Sunday and
Innovative said [__] hello to you
that's what you're [__] trying to
tell me how did you get real Stein gray
oh I was I was in the main room on a
Tuesday night I did a spot they in the
black show what are you talking about
and here I am all the time so it's that
Ty of jealousy okay how he had an agent
and I didn't meanwhile I was getting
spots at The Improv the store and the LA
wow you know 3 months in I was already
on the board yeah cuz I knew Gilbert
esal so he put me up Mondays at the
Laugh Factory The Improv lik me and I
was a regular at the store but that's
all I had going on right so I couldn't
figure out the
hostility of these older comics and it
was like you you dealt with three or
four of them from Tuesday to Thursday
then on the weekends they disappear and
do whatever [__] [__] [__] they did
and then you dealt with another handful
of them and Charlie Hill was a good guy
Allan Stevens was a great Alan Stevens
got me on [__] aress opposite James
Coburn he saw me at the store he's like
I got a roll for you it's coming up
trust me and all a sudden they called me
they gave me the [__] role Charlie
Hill was an Indian guy I never forget
him pulling me aside going listen you
gave you made you gave me belly LS keep
doing what you're doing right you know
don't get me wrong there was two or
three of them that were gentlemen but
there was 10 of them that were just
there to watch you [__] fail so they
could talk about you so that's why I
give you guys all the respect that's
what I wanted to tell thank you man I
appreciate that man someday when you get
older and young guys will be there I'll
do that you're going to go you know what
man I'm going to give these young guys
the respect because I know what they go
through in their daily life yeah you got
a bunch of nose man so sometimes an
older guy comes up to you and say dog
that ain't about Dick yeah get up
tomorrow morning like you got the
lottery ticket in your pocket watch what
happen
[__] remember where I heard it man [__]
these [__] what up lee lee San
Diego the 17th is already sold out awes
so we're thinking of adding the second
show you're going to be up in the
mountains giving Mama the high hard one
up in [__] Utah up there giving Mama
the Minka juice huh what date you got
coming up my brother I got uh coming up
I got um Pittsburgh the I got Boston the
17th and 18th of uh of this month okay
December sorry I'm a little high laugh
Boston I got laugh Boston that's a great
Club yeah laugh Boston the 18th and 19th
actually I think it is don't forget to
go to legal and tell them Le s you get
10% off really yep a great yeah done
I've heard of it I worked there for two
years and I got um and then I got uh Jan
Oh I got Pittsburgh January 6 through
8th I think it is you got a Netflix
special yeah 8th through 11th uh 6
through 10th in Pittsburgh something
like that which I'm proud of you cuz you
got the shoot in your home state thanks
like a [__] New Orleans baby
holding down the South trying to man it
was it was awesome man I had I never
felt so much love and support from my
hometown and all the people I grew up
with that just came out to [__] it
just like blew my mind man like it was
like kind of like validated like all the
[__] negative thoughts you have when
you're a kid you know is it's like oh
man maybe these people like thought I
was an okay person you know I don't know
how old were you the first time you left
Covington to go to New Orleans is an
adventure by yourself without the
parents to get your dicks off oh 15 did
you get your dick dick sucked yeah I got
my dick sucked wasn't great but I'm
lightly sucked pretty much by this girl
when you were 15 you were already a man
no no no no I was but you you you know I
was getting out there you were getting
but I'm talking what was your mentality
like having an older Dad having oh I
knew I was very aware okay very aware
and you were more aware than the kids
your age you just didn't say nothing
because you'd have to say why you knew
these things yeah and then you seem
weird I feel like if you try to like
explain yourself you've always felt a
little out of that's the way I've always
yeah I've always felt a little I've
always felt pretty as you get older you
talk about it but you still Twitches
like I couldn't tell these stories 15
years ago I tell now there's no [__]
way well dude watching guys like you is
[__] inspires like guys like me so
much man cuz it's like you just say
whatever like I'll literally after
seeing one of your sets I'm like how
does he I just to get to that spot in
your life where you can just be so open
about [__] that's it's unreal man it's
cool it's inspiring thanks man thanks
for what you do I don't
understand you work hard you come out
here you develop and all a sudden you
get some guy that goes you know Theo I
really like your southern style but I
really like you for you to
do uh a more family show that I could
pitch yeah and then you go to Lee on the
side and go hey Lee man you're a pretty
good writer hook me up in the afternoons
and let's write together yeah and you
write this act that isn't you yeah and
oh it' be tough man you understand could
imagine you understand I'm trying to say
to you so I I I when I got here I was so
desperate there was times I didn't have
a voice I'm not going to lie to anybody
yeah every comedian goes through that
where you come here and they confuse you
a little bit because you thought you had
the goods but now you start hearing
things and it's like Ronda Rousey right
now Ronda Rousey is not in hell because
she got knocked out right Ronda Rousey
doesn't know where the drawing board
where to start right so it's the same
thing for Comics like you don't know
you get the wind knocked out of you it's
it's I don't even know what the [__] I
was doing it happens man it's intense no
worries I have I've text this person I
was going to meet at 9: right now and
just let them know that I'm [__] let
me do the [__] sponsors here and
we'll get you the [__] out of here no I
don't mean that I don't want to go I'm
just say no no no no no no don't worry
about we're going to get the [__] out of
here any we're going to Jiu-Jitsu party
Joey he's going to do a couple back
flips like circus diesa oh I'll watch
that [__] dude I'll watch that [__] uh
the only other thing I got is I have my
Netflix special coming out at the end of
February so check it out it's called no
offense and uh and thanks for the love
man thanks for having me on too hey man
you know I love you to death like I said
I love all these young guys I love
watching you all my friends love you man
and I go home at night and I think about
it I go wow you know it's nice I could
talk to all those younger guys it's nice
that they don't treat me like I'm
lurking that's why I go to the store I
do my spot and I leave oh dude you have
the maximum respect because I don't want
to be like the old guy look at [__]
Joey de is smoking pot with young kid
you should be ashamed of himself I am
[__] ashamed of myself it's you
shouldn't I'm like a grandpa I should be
at home [__] mending a sweater and
rubbing Lee's feet in the
future you be rubing my feet whatever if
I was your grandpa you know me I'm a
dirty Grandpa anyway let's talk about
[__] underwear all right it needs to
be comfy snug in all the right places it
needs to look good and feel good I mean
that's the you know you just don't want
to wear underwear that's comfy you want
the world's most comfortable underwear
and that's meundies plain and [__]
simple okay I love meundies you know why
because it's got mold every pair of
meundies is made of micro moldi fabric
which doesn't sound sexy right now but
once you feel your meundies you'll never
go back to wearing regular underwear
ever ever ever again when I go to
Jiu-Jitsu I go to a gym now that's all I
wear is yeah because I don't want my nut
sack to pop out oh I got that old man
syndrome meundies it keeps them tight
warm that pulls the sweat away from your
skin your moisture I've been in a
position one time when I had the knee
surgery I had the same underwear on for
like 18 hours that's good feeling that
night I went to take my underwear I
thought my nut sack was going to smell
and be moist it was fresh that's when I
got sold on meundies when I had the
[__] surgery so let me tell you
something with meundies you'll feel more
comfortable than ever before plus that
Mees has a ton of different colors to
choose from it's the only place you're
going to find the same styles for him
and for her and they got a new signature
design every month they also just
launched a new box of line it's like
wearing nothing at all only better and
with the holidays holidays around the
corner Mees makes a perfect gift I think
it's a little too late right now but you
know what [__] it give it to them a
little late before New Year's you know
you never see the [__] on the
25th anyway agreed all right so do me a
favor these are not your parents
stocking stuffers but who cares get them
a pair anyway your dad needs some action
everybody needs me on these I don't care
how old you are everybody needs a pair
of Mees so go to meundies.com right now
Joey and you're gonna get 20% off your
first order plus all orders in the US
and Canada tell them Lee they ship for
free always me even has a money back
guarantee if you don't love your first
pair you get to keep them and you get
the full refund bam plus the tax that
means you have nothing to lose okay
what's today's date December 10th boom
so if you order meundies before December
13th your meundies will be arrive on
time for Christmas plain and [__]
simple that means you got till
bam Sunday to order meundies go to
meundies right now and get 20% off your
first order on the world's most
comfortable [__] underwear head to
head with any other pair underwears go
to meundies.com jooy right now that's
meundies.com Joey right now I got the
[__] leopard one with the sabotage
what's that with the with the swirl I
love those are my favorite ones the
black ones are a little too tight then
they sent me these long pants I cut
those into underwear that's the best
investment I ever we I took it to the
Armenian [__] SE she seed them down
they're like loose boxes you have no
idea how comfortable meundies is go to
meundies.com right now and get SL Joey
and get 20% off your first order and
free shipping in US and Canada Le what
is going on with you tonight I had a
cough drop but it got like super strong
I don't know if it's cuz I'm high it
might cough drop yeah is your mom going
to be [__] pissed bro it's going to
be interesting I'm I'm praying to God
she's asleep
this you have to uh you got to Periscope
that dude yeah Periscope your mom coming
in yelling at you looking at your
eyeballs where your eyeballs Lee know
why you ey but stop and get some
Visine so you don't look so [__]
obvious [__] suck anyway my favorite
people in the world especially now over
the holidays let me tell you something
there's no better gift than the gift of
on it onit's got listen Alpha Brain 100%
money back guaranteed shroom Tech sport
shroom Tech immune hemp hor protein
kettle bells weights weighted vest te I
mean listen I can't sit here and tell
you all the great products they got do
me a favor go to hit.com right now and
press in church boom and get 10% off
your first order me I'm a hemp protein
cocoa type of dude and I also like the
shroom Tech sport before I go to
Jiu-Jitsu I'm still out of shape I'm
still a fat [__] but at least I go I
want to congratulate my brother Lee for
taking third place in the [__] John
jock Christmas tournament while we're
talking about H it he didn't take shroom
Tech if not he would have taken first
place anyway back to [__] uh
all right here we
go you ever looking for a you ever go to
magazine you're looking for a particular
article it's a pain the ass to find but
guess what texture will carry your
favorite magazine let me let's get into
something about the magazines
here Texas is the app that gives you an
all access pass to the world's best
magazines right on your phone or tablet
browse through hundreds of magazines and
cherry pick the articles that interest
you the most the texture editorial team
recommends stories for you daily plus
their curated collections let you dive
into deeper into the topics sign up for
Tex you right now and then me a seconds
gain Insider access to the very best
reads plus exclusive content with full
access to top magazines across just
every interest text is the one present
to open again and again do me a favor
Tex is offering my listeners a free
trial right now when you go to tex.com
Joey even better give texia as a gift
between now and December 31st think
about it you'll gain unrestricted access
to the world's best magazines from back
issues from Hot Rod diabetic living
Entertainment Weekly diabetic
weekly you making a lot of suen free
donuts
we got to start that one again Le right
disregard that past that listen for You
magazine readers let me tell you what I
got for you guys for the holidays all
right two words one word texture.com all
right texture.com will get listen all I
know is magazines are a pain in the ass
you ever go to People magazine it says
it got a story in there and you got to
go through the pages 8 da da da da da da
texture cuts that in half text is the
app that gives you all access past to to
the world's best magazines right on your
phone or tablet you get to browse
hundreds of magazines and cherry-pick
the articles that interest you the most
the text editorial team recommends
stories for you daily plus their curated
collections let you dive deeper into the
topics that interest you signup protects
you right now in a Mia section second
you're going to gain Insider access to
the very best reads plus exclusive
content with the full access to the top
magazines just about every interest
texia is the one present that they'll
open again and again let me tell you the
magazines you got on texia all right you
got Bloomberg markets Bloomberg Business
Week Money sense Runners World Rolling
Stone 17 CLE muh you got you got Vanity
Fair Woman's Day the New Yorker Town's
today's parents Surfer teen vog The
Hollywood Reporter I could go on for an
hour all the magazines they got the best
thing is Texas is offering my listeners
a free trial right now when you go to
texas.com Joey even better give texture
as a gift between now and December 31st
think about it you'll gain unrestricted
access to the world's best magazines
from back issues to the one on news
stands today order this fantastic gift
for your loved one before December 31st
try texture for free right now when you
go to texture.com
Joey listen man you're going to fly you
want to read certain magazines you
download them before you go on the
flight you pop open your tablet and
there's your [__] articles that you
want to read everything you read right
in front of you plus it gets deeper it
goes to certain articles other articles
that might interest you but listen do me
a favor the only way you're going to
know for sure is go to texture.com Joey
and order right now you're going to get
a free trial when you go to texture.com
jooy you can download articles and the
whole issues for offline reading plus
you can share your subscription with the
entire family all right that's on what
they so that means it's basically a gift
for you if you think about it I like it
then you share the subscription with
your your entire family so then you get
to you get to see the magazines and let
me tell you what else I got for you guys
because I'm giving you all the action I
got before the holiday so you don't go
Joey what the [__] you don't tell me
what you got it's the holiday
season you don't know you show up at
these [__] places you don't know what
to buy these [__] people you know
like right now I'm looking at gift cards
or whatever Le scratching his head hats
you don't know what to give people I got
the [__] answer for your questions
and it's cheap too and it gets delivered
right to your door you ready for this I
know what it is Club W you're like Joey
what the hell is Club W Club W is a is a
is a what do they call it a wine what do
they call it the wine club wi
subscription but it's a wine
subscription but it's something it's the
uh grape to glass wine Revolution what
that means is let me break it down for
you even better for 9,000 years people
been making wine that's how long people
been confused about which wine to drink
red white
chardonay you get a headache after they
drink the wine but for many of us it's
the shopping that causes the real
headache so many choices what to learn
they chewing chicken they got beef and
there's no guarantee you even like what
you buy all right let me tell you
something it's tough getting a bottle of
wine especially in the holidays you got
to stop Park do this blah blah blah blah
I hate all that stuff this is why I
recommend this morning anything I joined
the new wine club clubw they change the
whole game it's easy you go to Club
w.com that's clubw
and you answer six simple questions
their algorithm creates a pallet profile
just for you let's say you like fruity
wines you like sweet wines b b Bop if
you want to eat chicken then they send
the wine directly to your door perfectly
customized to match your taste Club W is
the leading grape to glass wine
Revolution they work directly with The
Vineyards and they cut out the middleman
R which saves you dough so with Club W
you get premium wine customized to your
taste at a third of what they pay for at
the store you even have a no risk 100
money 100% guarantee that you'll love
what they send you let's do this let's
end the [__] drama here right now
club club W is offering my listeners 50%
off your first order when you go to
clubw
docomo that's clubw do.com joeey stop
wasting time stop and blah blah blah
messing around at retail stores start
drinking you know you're going to love
[__] go to clubw docomo and get 50% off
your first order and then this whole
holiday [__] with the [__] wine
all right that's Club w.com jooy I want
to thank clubw I want to thank texture I
want to thank meundies and I want to
thank on it the reason why I was
giggling was there's a candle right
there and all I kept thinking about how
that candle is going I light that piece
of paper is that a lollipop stick in
there that's a beautiful that's a wick
so everything's beautiful everybody's
co- pathetic here we'll be back Sunday
night we might be back Saturday we might
do our own little fight companion on uh
what is it Periscope we don't know what
we're going to do I want to thank my
main man theovon I want to thank my main
man lee sciatico over here with this bad
[__] head do little eyeballs
and that's it guys I'll see you next
week don't forget next Thursday San
Diego then after that I'm at ventur at
the Chinese restaurant the 23rd really
amen yeah you come come amen
yeah
cool thank you
f